so uh i know we can't talk spoilers um
but i am curious for both of you which
friends and family members constantly
ask you for spoilers on the show and
you're like i can't tell you anything
i don't know i think i i mean my circle
is like pretty damn nice pretty solid i
think yeah they they um they are
obviously like curious and stuff but
like i think they have the respect for
themselves where they're like okay well
i want to watch just because they're
already like you know fans of it so i i
guess i'm lucky in that sense you know
what i'm saying like um but yeah
yeah yeah my family have learned not to
ask anymore
between the two of you guys who is the
first to set and who is the one that is
waiting in the trailer uh
first to set waiting in the trailer
between the two of us yeah i think we
both got there on time and we were both
waiting in the trailer
yeah we were playing we had a lot of
down time and charlie we were just
playing nintendo like
it's like early early morning to like
yeah hurry up and wait yeah you'd drive
there in the dark and get there and
hours will pass and you go home in the
dark yeah yeah yeah it's so funny yeah
that's the thing i think a lot of people
don't realize about making um a movie or
a television show is what goes on behind
the scenes that it's not just you know
super glamorous if you know what i mean
oh for sure i mean this season you know
being in the dead a lot of it was in the
desert over albuquerque and sandstorms
blowing through sands yeah it was like
the whole crew covered in sand i mean i
i actually yeah you know i actually
burnt my scalp this year i mean just
being out yeah just being happy yeah
it's so powerful so powerful
but you kind of know it's it's also a
lot it's like a nice luxury to be like
that this is what i'm doing yeah
one of the things that i think is so
impressive about season four and
different than the other seasons is that
this really expands the world you're not
just in hawkins i mean it's out there
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of the season um yeah it's a it's a it's
a big aspect it's like it's the first
real you know i think that slogan that
we're not in hawkins anymore and
it's just opened the scope and it's
allowed them to be able to to tell
you know that the three
different like total fields of storyline
and uh
you know we have this almost levity
going on and and there's just you know
there's still drama there and there's
that but it but yeah it's different to
what's going on in hawkins and uh it's
yeah it's allowed them to expand the
story and i i hope that kind of people
you know like that about it oh
they will i can give you a little update
right now for sure
um
so one of the things i i really think is
so impressive about matt and ross is
that they are able to have this huge
cast where every character feels like
they have a story line with like a
beginning middle and end can you sort of
talk about the writing on the show and
matt and ross's ability to just to do
that which is really impressive
yeah i mean
i think it blows
but they blow everything out
yeah they blow everything out of the
water every season every season i think
all of us as cast members we we're all
anticipating where it's going to go and
every time they they just i don't know
they pull it off but it's also so rich
you know like you say they do add loads
of characters but the characters always
feel in the world they always feel
grounded and even when they're going
through the supernatural
experience it's still grounded in that
reality
which is such a skill and then also to
be able to pull from so many different
films and be able to
you know i keep saying this the first
season would be like an e.t uh uh
goonies you know they this season you
know there is that they've been able to
just be like pull from nightmare on elm
street or pull from these darker themes
as the showman chose
matures and
and and then execute it i think they
execute it as filmmakers so well like
you know the the style you know i i
i grew up in the noise but i did watch
you know portland iceland i watched uh
nightmare on elm street and and and this
you know it doesn't feel modern when you
know the way that they
they shoot it and i think they they nail
it perfectly yeah listen guys congrats
on the season people are going to love
it thank you so much for your time
yeah thank you you got an awesome shelf
in the back man i see ed 209 back there
uh
is that is that uh
is that beast wars megatron
uh no that it's donnie darko ed 209 oh
that's the um real steel and this is
like uh uh like japanese anime like
gotcha man and guy king and grandizer i
thought on the second shelf i thought
that was b-sports megatron my bad no
it's all good i mean it's you know it's
hard i know you have a small monitor
yeah but right here i don't know why the
shape of it looks like all i see is like
the t-rex head right there and then the
feet right yeah anyway sorry that's not
important anyway no no it's all it's all
good thank you so much 30 seconds to
comply
[Laughter]
later
you